hello and welcome to this video playing
I am and broker and planet him recently
don't remember what game that was ok
playing a sideline of the ready system
here I'd have some very decent
experience with ya white zone position
sometimes is a little bit more
comfortable because of this I dmn and
lightsey for coming yeah it's this kind
of position I have played in a
tournament chess and it's very nice to
play because black as some basically
stuck with a somewhat and passive
position cannot too much always has to
defend that green side or give me the
bishop pair one of one of two scenarios
okay so how to do that now and maybe
kenal bit of space there okay now he
takes hmm I think I'll take with the
rook so it's not such a clear-cut
decision
yeah the thing is his Bishop here it's
not very stable d5 of course I never
take them and try to be a bit quick in
this game I saw I'm sort of remember
stuff against this person with the time
I don't know time being a factor I
should have gone to see to actually hurt
okay it's not a problem any or something
but always kick the night back but c2
would have been there somewhat better
square just being a bit more flexible
let's send over there going 45 now so be
sure to e5 that would be nice
nice testicle 97 now or in the near
future Bishop c7 is also a threat I came
and talking after work possible doubling
on the on the age file yeah what is this
ok I'm back yeah I was Christmas present
I'm not for me but ok what's the mailman
ok ok so I'm keeping things covered here
Bishop d3 is a bit of an annoyance hmm I
wonder do I mean can still play for the
Aged file but it's not sure how good
that is I think it's probably better to
just switch to the D file now and play
with that just play with the porn and he
has 97 and and so on but it doesn't
necessarily mean that he's ok here in
this position so how to do this hmm
Trading rooks I don't think so I don't
get around with the bishop to have six I
mean this is something that would be
would be nice
but if I do this actually and go
and go route you one next and can you
defend this or my rope t one takes takes
like a five Bishop f2 brings the king
over them it's very close to a fortress
it's very very close to a fortress
Oh check then I'm happy with that your
nose allows that
just have to avoid to be overexcited
about rogue age one check
check so how to win this may be around
to deform then a fun time morning isn't
even that easy I have to shoot 46 here
maybe check check
I need to invade here so this is what
I'm what I'm doing and Bishop is just
tons better than the night check check
nice out for look a five-year
unbelievable okay five ticks on g5 check
check it's a bit risky what I'm doing
here because of the time and jacket I
don't really want to give him a draw
nice position check and I probably have
to 19 seconds gradual this might have
sassman gain wow what a shame now I must
win this game that's annoying that's
really annoying completely out playing
him check check then just screwing it up
right at the end check and so this that
should slow should be just a winner ok
King you for not allowing this is easier
can check already still there's a
problem I still the final position is
probably winning Jan I'm pretty sure
about Jack King d7 is winning no okay
ma'am well 20 seconds and of yeah i mean
i have lost many games like that the
giant was just trying hanging in their
belly and we know time yeah that is
lettuce that will win with the sea porn
but still not so easy
yeah this whole position is somewhat
more comfortable from white because
black has very little that you can do
and yeah he tried with the bishop trade
but lost lots of time in the process yes
this is quite uncomfortable from like
already our Bishop g5 was was already
quite decisive and we should have six
and things like that yeah but ok that
was it was I'm totally fine with what i
did i played quickly and black one got
killed actually hit it was pretty pretty
good game up to that point where i am
sort of let the clock down alright
didn't actually I design check and it
was just slightly giant check check
check I just want to check your that way
I lost the crucial time I didn't find
something conclusive here and okay it is
not in there is nothing super easier
it's nothing super easy that that wins
just like that so it's some gap I should
have probably killed that over earlier
one thing definitely comes to mind is
here just to go back and just not let
him take because when this position is
just so dominating you you don't have to
do anything fancy you can just just play
like that or or this year and then drew
create something like that you cannot
cover that porn and at the end i will i
will invade with the King probably and
get the g6
this is what what the engine gives check
check know what and something like this
yeah I mean ok that's it is a busted
position but it takes a while to to to
win it at the end ok at least I go to
draw at the end not being completely
yeah being there without any any
anything to show ok thanks for watching